bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de par le break 2 45 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire bourgeois katia bonjour
michael est pour commenter l'actualité
riche cette semaine nous accueillons
xavier bertrand bonjour bonjour un
ministre sous la présidence de nicolas
sarkozy député de l'aisne et candidat à
la primaire de l'ump l'ump il en sera
largement question dans cette émission
mais d'abord l'actualité et il ya
beaucoup d'actualité on va revenir sur
la réforme territoriale acteurs de cette
semaine le chef de l'état a dévoilé sa
carte de france des régions elles seront
quatorze au lieu de 22 des élus grâce
des dents à droite comme à gauche la
suppression des départements elle
attendra 2020 alors nicolas sarkozy
candidat à la présidence de l'ump c'est
ce que souhaite son proche ami brice
hortefeux dans une interview au monde il
juge le retour de l'ancien président
nécessaire et le recours à une primaire
inutile les autres prétendants au poste
ne sont pas tous d'accord il rappelle
les statuts du parti et puis les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement du monde
réunis en normandie pour célébrer les 70
ans du débarquement le disait si je vois
44 on en parle dans l'autre plus de
l'hebdo avec un film qui va nous faire
revivre l'histoire de ce jour où tout a
basculé
la vie bertrand principe de cette
émission commence par le lundi bien
évidemment avec une réforme très
controversée qui est en discussion à
l'assemblée
certains la jugent laxiste d'autres tout
ça qu'ils disent est une urgence c'est
la réforme de christiane taubira sur la
réforme pénale qui est en discussion à
l'assemblée nationale à droite on
l'accuse de vouloir vider les prisons
vois ça avec thibault le floch le ton
était donné dès les questions
gouvernement où la droite a de nouveau
interpellé la majorité sur la réforme
pénale une réforme idéologique et
laxiste selon l'opposition réponse
cinglante du premier ministre notre pays
crève littéralement de ce genre de
polémique et de position
dire que nous souhaitons vider les
prisons dire que c'est madame taubira
qui souhaitent ville et les prisons n'a
aucun sens c'est un mensonge
et cela ne fait pas avancer le débat
d'un instant deux heures plus tard dans
un hémicycle nettement moins remplies le
ton se veut moins polémique plus
pédagogique en préambule la garde des
sceaux explique la nature de cette
réforme pénale et revient sur la
contrainte pénale tant décrié par la
droite la contrainte pénale ne supprime
pas la prison elle ne supprime pas la
prison y compris d'ailleurs pour les
courtes peines parce que si les
magistrats l'estiment justifié
ils pourront toujours prononcée des
courtes peines c'est une sanction et les
obligations et les interdictions feront
l'objet de suivi et de contrôle
ces contrôles obligatoires pour le
condamner dureront entre 6 mois et 5 ans
maximum et concerneront dans un premier
temps tous les délits punis d'une peine
maximum de cinq ans de prison la
question à savoir si la contrainte
pénale doit s'appliquer à tous les
délits ou non et qui a opposé
parlementaires et gouvernement devrait
être renvoyé à 2017 et cela ne satisfait
pas pour autant l'ump qui a déposé une
motion de rejet à l'encontre du texte
ces dispositions de votre texte sont
disparates et je lâche le mot tout de
suite laxistes
car elles ne permettront en aucun cas de
mieux lutter contre la récidive ni même
de rendre plus efficaces les sanctions
pénales qui seront dans les faits
dévitalisées l'opposition a déposé 300
amendements pour s'opposer à ce projet
de loi les discussions elles dureront
une trentaine d'heures dans l'hémicycle
xavier bertrand il ya un manque les
revenus beaucoup 1 dans ce sujet c'est
laxistes tout ce qui n'est pas tout
sécuritaire et laxiste faut pas
caricaturer c'est suffisamment sérieux
pour qu'on ne caricature pas ces
questions là ce qui est vrai c'est que
madame taubira cherche effectivement à
éviter la prison aux délinquants c'est
ça son si je sais pas nouveau elle a
toujours été dans cette logique là c'est
une idéologue conte à la tête d'un
ministère l'idéologie est un danger
quelle qu'elle soit l'idéologie tout
sécuritaire c'est pas la bonne 11
l'idéologie lac si ce n'est pas la bonne
certainement une autre voie il ne trouva
c'est tout simplement de faire preuve de
fermeté
d'autorité de vouloir rétablir l'ordre
ne pas chercher d'excusés social salle
excuses social c'est le registre de
valable taubira mais mais mais le ciel
l'assument est la même et saignant
commission d'aller contre l'avis
officiel du gouvernement pour faire
passer elle-même les positions encore
plus laxistes elle a été rappelée à
l'ordre et puis on le voit bien un peu
le testament de madame taubira c'est son
dernier on sent bien qu'elle n'a pas
envie de rester elle est restée pour des
contingences politiques politiciennes
mais elle fait du mal à la société
française et elle fait du mal à notre
ordre judiciaire et aux besoins de
sécurité et d'ordre qu'il ya dans le
pays ressentie par les français mais en
quoi ne pas chercher automatiquement la
prison c'est être idéologue vous faire
preuve de laxisme encore une fois je
répète les nous mêmes on a pu nous faire
ce reproche également d'avoir pu donner
le choix des alternatives à la prison
mais quand même la suppression des
peines planchers l'exemple type
les peines plancher avait été beaucoup
décrié elles ont été énormément
appliquée par les magistrats pourquoi
les supprimer alors c'est pourtant le
choix madame taubira pourquoi parce que
ça avait été mise en place sous le
quinquennat précédent vous savez ce qui
lie avec les peines-plancher c'est que
le délinquant récidiviste
multirécidiviste se disait qu'il n'y
avait plus l'impunité la pire des choses
c'est le fait qu'on se dise il n'y aura
pas forcément de sanctions et que cette
sanction ne sera pas forcément appliquer
la peine plancher permettait de se dire
qu'il n'y avait plus d'impunité qu'on ne
passait plus au travers des gouttes de
la justice et side est rayé d'un trait
il n'empêche pas forcément les récidives
notamment l'argument des du gouvernement
elle n'empêche pas la récidive mais elle
évite la récidive l'empêcher qui peut
garantir aujourd'hui dans notre système
il ya 100 % de réussite personnes mais
entre les résultats qu'il va y avoir
avec cette loi et les 100% mon dieu il y
a une telle marge qui fait que les
braves gens eux ne se sentent plus en
sécurité parce qu'il ya l'action de la
police c'est vrai il ya toute une action
de prévention laquelle je crois mais il
y a le besoin d'autorité d'ordre de son
sort dans ma ville 50 ha j'ai fait de la
sécurité une vraie priorité avec un
renforcement de la police municipale de
développement de la vidéoprotection mais
j'ai aussi j'ai aussi des
diether j'ai aussi des gens qui sont là
pour baisser la tension qui dans les
halls d'immeubles sont là pour dialoguer
et rappeler un certain nombre de règles
je marche bien sûr de gens que je marche
sur ses deux jambes la prévention mais
aussi la certitude de la sanction et
l'application de sécurité sont vos mots
penser que ce ne sont pas ceux de manuel
valls et ce ne sont pas ceux de
christiane taubira il ya deux petites
différentes j'étais ministre un ministre
est jugé sur ses résultats si on s'en
tient à ce constat
manuel valls est l'un des plus mauvais
ministre de l'intérieur que l'on ait
connu beaucoup déclaration beaucoup de
coups de menton mais en définitive la
délinquance a explosé comme rarement il
y a plusieurs phénomènes qu'ils étaient
plutôt saluée pour ses initiatives
notamment sur matière de sécurité moi je
crois au résultat il ya des problèmes et
ce cas les solutions manuel valls n'a
pas été un ministre de l'intérieur des
résultats et je crois qu'il faut
remonter à daniel vaillant pour avoir un
aussi mauvais bilan de la part d'un
ministre de l'intérieur voilà pourquoi
je ne lui faisait pas confiance en tant
que ministre de l'intérieur c'est pas
pour autant que je lui faire crédit en
tant que premier ministre loin s'en faut
alors on parle d'une autre réforme
xavier bertrand attendu et redouté enfin
dévoilé la réforme territoriale
françois hollande a des lois doit
dévoiler sa carte de france des régions
il en propose 14 au lieu de 22 une
première étape pour simplifier
l'organisation territoriale et une
réforme avec beaucoup de zones d'ombré
qui fait grincer des dents à droite
comme à gauche explications de jean
baptiste daoulas à peine annoncée la
réforme territoriale et déjà attaqué par
l'opposition l'ump et lui dit interpelle
directement manuel valls vous improviser
sans aucune concertation une réforme
totalement bâclée tous les ingrédients
d'un échec sont réunis vous même vous
avez proposé la suppression le roman des
régions vous avez proposé la suppression
des départements et parce que cette
majorité le fait vous n'êtes pas
d'accord c'est précisément ça que nos
concitoyens ne veulent plus la nouvelle
carte des régions a été entièrement
dessiné depuis les visées mais la
majorité joue désormais la carte de la
concertation avec l'opposition
je suis pour qu'il y ait des échanges
avec l'opposition sur une réforme qui
doit rassembler très largement et sur
laquelle le président de la république
l'a dit le parlement doit jouer tout son
rôle la porte est donc ouverte à des
ajustements pendant la discussion du
texte à l'assemblée mais l'opposition a
été échaudé par la méthode hollande pas
question de faciliter la tâche du
gouvernement sur la réforme territoriale
nous étions à lui dit ouvert à la
fabrication territoriales mais les
conditions dans lesquelles les choses se
font sont
impossibles à suivre mais dans quel pays
sommes nous d'un pas un pays au monde où
on aurait à redécoupage annoncé par à
présent dalle public par un communiqué
de presse avec une heure sera produite
en fin
on est dans un monde de fous les
discussions commenceront au sénat en
juillet le gouvernement espère avoir
bouclé la première lecture du texte
avant les vacances d'été alors vous êtes
député de l'aisne qui se trouve en
picardie la picardie mariée de force
avec la champagne ardenne c'est votre
sentiment et qu'est ce que vous ferez ce
que vous voterez ce texte et à quelles
conditions
je suis favorable à une réforme
territoriale je le dis depuis des années
et je ne vais pas changer d'avis
aujourd'hui c'est une bonne idée de
réforme mais c'est une méthode
lamentable je ne suis pas le seul à le
dire beaucoup d'élus socialistes dans
les couloirs nous disait que si françois
hollande avait voulu planter la réforme
c'est ce qu'ils disent il ne s'y serait
pas pris autrement d'autres raconte même
que le premier ministre lui aurait
demandé au président de ne pas s'en
occuper s'il voulait qu'elle aboutit
cette réforme je vais vous dire ce à
quoi je crois déjà sur la bonne méthode
en 2014 vous ne décidez plus tout seul
dans votre bureau même si c'est le
bureau de l'elysée et vous ne brille
connais pas une nouvelle carte sur un
coin de table de référendum d'abord on
ne pose pas les bonnes questions en tout
cas on ne vote pas pour la voie de
réponse vous ne savez pas quel type de
référendum je fais allusion locale non
c'est pas ça il ya des vins principe
c'est comme la réforme des rythmes
scolaires pensé par un ministre ou
celles dans son bureau qui s'applique à
tout le monde les gens ne supportent
plus ça s'est fini c'est plus la france
de 2014 vous ne décidez pas tout seul tu
en voilà allez je mette la carte et puis
encore des pays de la loire avec
bretagne serait du sens mais comme sur
le drian a mis sa démission dans la
balance et bien effectivement monsieur
ayrault pays de la loire s'est retrouvé
tout seul parce que madame royal voulait
pas de lui les ministres de la
république ne se sont pas comportés en
ministre ils se sont comportés en baron
en barons régionaux cette conception
éthique de la politique ils ne l'ont pas
en tête ils ne sont pas à la hauteur de
leurs fonctions je vais jusqu'au bout
parce que je ne cherche aucun prétexte
cette réforme je suis prêt à la voter si
elle répond à plusieurs critères
disparition des conseils généraux mais
maintenant pas dans six ans pas le cas
maintenant panossian le gouvernement
peut écouter deuxièmement disparition de
plusieurs milliers d'élus locaux j'y
suis favorable diminution du nombre de
régions je suis favorable la seule chose
que je demande c'est que même si c'est
un référendum consultatif indicatif que
l'on demande par exemple aux picards
mais c'est vrai pour d'autres régions
il y a plusieurs options sur la table
avec qui pensez-vous que cela le plus de
sens de vous regrouper et au final si
c'est pas clair c'est le gouvernement
qui tranchera c'est un drame mais comme
moi on demande l'avis des gens
d'ailleurs si le gouvernement ne leur
demande pas leur avis les gens donneront
leur avis ils donneront leur avis
certainement par internet peut être en
ayant des référendum spontané organisé
ou lors des élections je souhaite
aujourd'hui que l'on écoute davantage
les français il y à 1000 fois plus de
bon sens sur le terrain qu ailleurs pour
le reste pour le reste cette réforme là
on appelle forcément une autre tout de
suite c'est que si vous diminuez le
nombre de régions si vous diminuez le
nombre d'etf long il va falloir aussi
bien inscrire dans les textes la place
de la ruralité parce que vous ne pouvez
pas donner le sentiment des millions de
français qui vivent dans les campagnes
que n'existent plus qu'il n'y en a que
pour les grandes métropoles que pour les
grandes régions il faut donc consacrer
la place des communes respecter le fait
communal les 36000 communes de france se
sont pas elles qui dépensent beaucoup ce
ne sont pas elles qui coûte de l'argent
les grandes métropoles coûte de l'argent
le doublon coûte de l'argent mais pas
les petites communes et le dernier point
c'est que je crois qu'il faudra changer
le mode de scrutin dans les régions
parce que plus les régions sont grandes
et semble s'éloigner il faut revenir ce
crétin pour un mode de scrutin où vous
avez comme pour les élections cantonales
d'avant un lien entre l'élu le
territoire et la population et pour ma
part je travaille à autre chose c'est
que si vous diminuer le nombre d'élus on
ne peut pas garder le même nombre de
parlementaires motive ça n'est
absolument pas possible on ne peut pas
donner l'impression qu'il ya une
forteresse assemblée nationale une
forteresse henao landina l'on touche à
rien pour nous on touche à rien parce
que si la classe politique ne comprend
pas qu'il faut aussi qu'elles fassent
des efforts ou des sacrifices c'est
qu'elle a rien compris à ce qui se passe
enfin retravailler ses succès aux
élections européennes travaillent
actuellement sur cette question vous
pouvez faire des propositions à ce que
la aujourd'hui nous sommes seuls chaîne
parlementaire vous valez un petit peu
plus loin nous expliquer je mords sont
en consultation il s'agit pas de rentrer
dans une course en 10 ans et 200 députés
de -300 pourquoi parce que ce que je
suis en train de regarder avec un
certain nombre de mes amis c'est
département par département quelle est
la bonne représentation pour que les
gens se sentent représentés représentés
ont fait pas une réforme avec une une
règle à calcul c'est pas comme ça voilà
il faut appeler les comptables en
politique mais si vous voulez respecter
l'essence de la politique la
représentation et la mission je pense
qu'il faudrait nous retrouver avec un
nombre de parlementaires qui situerait à
peu près au dessus de 400 mais pas
beaucoup plus au dessus de 400 ce qui
permettrait d'avoir chaque département
représenté est de pouvoir avoir à la
fois avec le non cumul des mandats des
parlementaires qui est le temps à
l'assemblée mais qu'ils puissent aussi
vraiment représenter la population
donc je pense que pour les députés c'est
au dessus de 400 certainement le chiffre
d' équilibre et en ce qui concerne les
sénateurs il faudrait être en dessous de
250 de façon à pouvoir montrer très
clairement que si la carte de france des
régions se transforme des territoires se
transforme la carte des députés des
sénateurs se transforme obligatoire mais
savait très bien que que ce soit à
droite ou à gauche moi pas vraiment être
d'accord avec tout ça j'imagine nouveaux
amis parlementaires n'ont pas forcément
d'accord mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est
que les français soient d'accord donc
c'est encore un référendum forcément moi
c'est ce j'ai en tête vous savez que sur
le plan des institutions je fais des
propositions qui plaisent pas c'est vrai
un nombre de mes collègues j'assume je
suis pour le septennat non renouvelable
de façon à ce qu'un président élu ne
pense pas sa réélection et qu'ils se
consacrent qu'à sa mission je plaide
également pour le recours au référendum
en début de mandat pour avoir la force
de porter les réformes et je plaide
aussi pour un changement du nombre de
parlementaires mais ça se fera par
référendum parce que les français sont
beaucoup moins conservateur que la
classe politique questions très précises
pour venir un tout petit peu sur le
texte qu'on a abordé au début ce projet
territorial 2017 vous revenez au pouvoir
vous abroger ce texte non
je souhaite je revendique la cohérence
c'est pas parce que françois hollande
avait dit à l'époque qu'il fallait rien
faire
on attendait c'est pas fini monsieur
leroux disais tout à l'heure on va
verser retrait s'il écoute je fais des
propositions précises concrètes ce texte
le principe d'une réforme territoriale
j'ai envie de voter le plus tôt possible
le plus tôt possible parce que c'est
aussi une autre marque est ce que la
classe politique est capable de
comprendre ce qui se passe c'est ce
qu'elle est capable de comprendre
qu'elle doit aussi consentir des
sacrifices
c'est ça la vérité avec matteo renzi qui
a réussi sa fin pour qu'est ce qui
bloque en france parce que on le voit
bien aidé à ta petite politique allons
jusqu'au bout des choses
pourquoi cette réforme là devient
aujourd'hui l'actualité la plus brûlante
président de la république qui en
janvier nous disait que c'était pas
l'enjeu pourquoi parce qu'il est
incapable de réussir sur le front de
l'emploi il est incapable de faire
reculer le chômage alors qu'est ce qu'il
fait il fait diversion il a commencé à
faire diversion sur le plan des réformes
de société le mariage pour tous qui a
fragilisé qui a coupé la france est
aujourd'hui le fait sur le champ
institutionnel
parce que tout simplement comme il ne
réussit pas sur le plan économique il
cherche à faire diversion jeudi auprès
d'un public attention les français ne
sont pas dupes les français voient tout
ils savent tous ils sont tous et vous
n'échapperez pas à vos responsabilités
et les responsabilités première c'est de
faire reculer le chômage j'avais 4 ans
il a ouvert le dossier ump
son retour est une nécessité c'est beau
sur ceux de brice hortefeux dans une
interview au monde ce retour c'est celui
de nicolas sarkozy qui brigue ray point
d'interrogation la présidence de l'ump
on voit tous avec elisa bartholomé ce
n'est pas une nouvelle carte postale
toute la journée les proches de nicolas
sarkozy sont passés à l'offensive pour
préparer le retour de l'ancien président
premier à s'exprimer l'un des plus
proches collaborateurs brice hortefeux
dans une interview au monde il déclare
le retour de nicolas sarkozy qui était
une possibilité
devient une nécessité
je souhaite donc qu'il soit candidat à
la présidence de l'ump à l'automne nous
avons besoin d'un chef d'un projet et
d'un cap la stratégie de l'ancien
président est clair nicolas sarkozy veut
à tout prix éviter la primaire s'il est
élu président du parti il compte sur sa
popularité auprès des militants pour
s'imposer comme le candidat naturel de
l'ump une volonté qui va à l'encontre de
la règle que voudrait édictées alain
juppé le président du parti ne sera pas
candidat en 2017 une règle défendue par
l'entourage de françois fillon et alain
juppé candidat déclaré à la primaire et
adversaire de nicolas sarkozy
si nicolas sarkozy envie de se présenter
à l'élection présidentielle de 2017 il
peut tout à fait respecté les règles qui
ont été posées collectivement d'une
participation aux primaires quand on est
fort on n'a pas peur de primaire quand
on est fort on n'a pas peur d'une
élection en mp dans un système on prend
le parti pour être le candidat à la
présidentielle on est dans un système
chacun se présente aux primaires avec un
projet pour les français pas seulement
pour les militants au contraire dans
l'entourage de nicolas sarkozy
l'organisation d'une primaire est de
plus en plus critiqué des statuts et
l'ump sont très sont très souples à cet
égard et on peut très bien imaginer
demain que le président de l'ump soit
également un autre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle mais pour moi il y en a
qu'un qui remplit cette condition et qui
peut être à la fois président de l'ump
est notre candidat pour l'élection
présidentielle c'est nicolas sarkozy
elle faut-il alors renoncer à
l'organisation d'une primaire pour
l'élection présidentielle jean pierre
raffarin l'un des membres du futur trio
de direction refuse de prendre parti
nous aurons une processus dément qu'un
processus démocratique pour décider
cette situation de manière tout à fait
là conforme à l'organisation de nos
statuts donc c'est une décision qui sera
une décision prise par les nouvelles
instances de l'ump statu quo donc
jusqu'au bureau politique de mardi
prochain françois fillon voudrait lui
que les statuts ne soit pas modifiable
avant cette fameuse primaire
débattra va ouvrir le dossier ump
frédéric dabi nous a rejoint directeur
général adjoint de l'ifop institut de
sondage avec vous on verra évidemment
les sondages autour nicolas sarkozy
xavier bertrand va être très précis
nombreuses questions première est ce que
c'est un putsch des sarkozystes
mais il faut savoir qui parle mais il a
dit qu'il est s'exprimer par le temps
que porte parole
alors on va pas je le sais mais bon non
mais vraiment on va jouer sur les mots
moi je les ai indiqué et je leur dis
très clairement
l'ump a vocation à écrire une nouvelle
page on pensait qu'il fallait qu'il
était possible d'écrire cette nouvelle
page avec l'élection en novembre 2012
après l'échec des élections
présidentielles on pensait que c'était à
ce moment là et là la guerre copé fillon
qui a failli aboutir à la disparition de
l'ump ne nous l'a pas permis c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire et cette guerre
ne s'est jamais vraiment terminé jamais
là aujourd'hui il ya une nouvelle donne
et pourquoi cette nouvelle donne il ya
la fois les révélations sur la sphère
bygmalion les révélations les
accusations de la part de protagonistes
et puis aussi le score des élections
européennes
parce que moi je n'oublie pas ce qui
s'est passé aux européennes le front
national est arrivé en premier et pas
d'un demi point largement en premier et
ça c'est un cataclysme il faut pas
l'oublier et on pense quoi la classe
politique pense qu'on peut continuer à
faire comme avant comme si rien ne
s'était passé ça fait longtemps qu'on
dit un jour madame le pen arrivera en
tête c'est ce qui s'est produit et moi
je le mesure dans ma ville aux élections
européennes je n'étais pas candidat donc
elle a fait 12 points de plus la liste
du fournas taux de nicolas sarkozy non
c'est pas ça c'est deux choses
différentes ces deux choses différentes
ça veut dire que si l'ump n'écrit pas
enfin cette nouvelle page si nous ne
bâtissons pas enfin une nouvelle l'ump
ce qui s'est passé aux élections
européennes peut se reproduire et l'ump
de purnell peut même être éliminé du
deuxième tour de la présidentielle ce
jour-là l'ump seraient mortes est ce
qu'il y à un danger pour l'ump
évidemment le départ la démission de
jean-françois copé je pense que c'était
quelque chose de nécessaire il l'a
compris mais ça ne suffit pas pour
rebâtir une nouvelle l'ump voilà
pourquoi il faut non pas refaire l'ump
d'avant mais il faut bâtir une nouvelle
ump une nouvelle l'ump excusez moi c'est
très important on est aussi en 2014 on
n'est plus dans les années 90 on n'est
plus au début des années 2000 on n est
pas que les gens veulent décider par
eux-mêmes ils veulent avoir du pouvoir
ils veulent pas s'exprimer une fois tous
les cinq ans ou tous les six ans aux
sélectionnés trop non j'aurais vraiment
fait social d'importants contrats au nom
de la cohérence c'est à dire que celui
qui est adhérent qu'est ce qu'il veut il
veut décider voilà pourquoi je souhaite
notamment qu'à toutes les élections le
candidat à la présidentielle les
candidats aux européennes est candidat
aux municipales même des candidats aux
élections législatives
ce soit l'adhérent qu'ils puissent voter
pour choisir et qu'on ne lui impose plus
jamais un choix venu d'en haut mais à
tous les niveaux et apparemment la story
ne sont pas claires sur l'organisation
des primaires que de que disent les
statuts daniel fasquelle a l'air de dire
qu'ils sont extrêmement clair que
distille ils sont extrêmement claires
ils disent que celui qui est à la tête
de l'ump s'il souhaite être candidat aux
primaires il doit se déporter c'est à
dire qu'il doit quitter ses fonctions
avant l'organisation des primaires c'est
aussi simple que cela rien ne l'interdît
rien ne l'interdît et cette règle vaut
pour moi qui ai indiqué mon intention
d'être candidat aux primaires mais aussi
pour tous ceux qui en ont la tension
mais qui n'ont pas encore déclaré voilà
mais je pose la question qui a peur du
choix des électeurs qui a peur du choix
des adhérents pourquoi avoir peur c'est
pas une primaire peut-être besoin
évidemment que pour tout cas pour les
sarkozystes si nicolas sarkozy arrive
plus besoin de primaires le chef revient
mais aussi c'est une conception de l'ump
qui est datée l'ump s'est pas seulement
une machine électorale pour savoir qui
sera le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il faut aussi préparer
des équipes pour les élections
régionales qui auront lieu même plus
tard il faut aussi faire vivre l'ump sur
le terrain on est connu une formidable
victoire aux élections tous ces élus là
tous ces élus ils ont besoin d'être
aidés d'être entouré de voir qu'à
travers leurs réussites locales on peut
aussi montrer pourquoi il ya une vraie
différence dans la gestion proposé par
des élus de l'ump par rapport à la
gauche
justement à l'instant sur un sondage
pour savoir qui est le mieux placé pour
reprendre l'ump la droite c'est le zoom
de la semaine avec vous frédéric dabi
donc sondage ifop pour l'hebdomadaire
valeurs actuelles à la question de la
personnalité qui est que les
sympathisants sympathisants du parti
soit devoir diriger partie cet automne
et bien une place nicolas sarkozy alain
juppé presque à égalité est ce que ça
veut dire que alain juppé a remplacé
nicolas sarkozy il est un petit peu trop
tôt pour le dire je n'ai pas honte de
dire qu'il faut être prudent vis-à-vis
de ce sondage puisque on ne sait pas
quelle sera l'offre pour les simples
pour les adhérents de l'ump lors du
congrès nous avons interrogé des
sympathisants de l'ump dans lequel il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'adhérents mais ce
sondage ifop heure actuelle est un vrai
tournant puisque pour la première fois
nicolas sarkozy et je dirais contesté
d'endurance dans tout à fait dans une
question vitale des sympathisants ump
sur nicolas sarkozy je dirais de france
lorsqu'on interroge de l'ensemble des
français à une nette majorité d'entre
eux 63 % dans un sondage ifop fiducial
pour itélé ne souhaite pas le retour de
nicolas sarkozy sur la scène politique
française mais quand on est sur le coeur
des sympathisants ump y il y avait une
sarko nostalgie et l'envi que négoce
sarkozy revienne dans ce cadre là après
la défaite des élections européennes
après laffaire d'igm à lyon qui a
fortement abîmé l'image de l'ump 1 - 30
auprès des sympathisants ump sur l'ump
un projet pour la france - 27 c des
chiffres absolument vertigineuse sur
l'ump et proche des préoccupations des
français les français en général et les
sympathisants de l'ump vous à une ump
autocentré qui se parlent à elle même et
qui a arrêté d'essayer d'incarner une
alternative pour l'ensemble des français
mais ce que vient de dire guy bertrand
est très juste sur un point les
adhérents des partis politiques ne
veulent plus voir plutôt attendre
d'abord d'un parti politique qu'ils
puissent eux-mêmes désigner leurs
candidats aux élections en 2009 ils
veulent pas fait une crise avec les
primes en 2009 qu'il veut pas fait une
enquête pour lise pour l'ump auprès des
adhérents de l'ump ce n'était pas une
enquête auprès des sympathisants la
première attente d'un adhérent de l'ump
c'était des jeunes adhérents les fameux
jeunes pop de l'époque ils veulent
pouvoir sélectionner et choisir
eux-mêmes leurs candidats aux élections
de ce point de vue là la période du
parti du rpr bonapartiste avec des chefs
s'est complètement fini c'est fini donc
il y aura des primaires pour vous c'est
écrit d'avancé mais c'est le choix des
adhérents et moi je ne laisserai
personne remettre en cause le choix des
adhérents je ne laisserai personne
remettre en cause l'organisation des
primaires c'est moderne les primaires ça
donne le pouvoir à l'adhérent c'est ce
que veulent aujourd'hui les gens et puis
aussi c'est pas une question de
personnes c'est une question de ligne
politique c'est une question d'éthique
des ti c'est à dire qu'on ne décide plus
d'en haut tout seul c'est ça le sujet
mais ce que je composais brice hortefeux
c'est une question politique mais faut
pas qu'on se trompe il a décidé de poser
la question des primaires en 10
anciennes incertitudes mais il ya une
incertitude visiblement aujourd'hui avec
ce que dit frédéric dabi lina certitude
on sait pas clairement quels le choix
des adhérents dont le moment venu ça
n'est pas maintenant je pense que les
primaires sont irremplaçables
indispensable mais en attendant les
primaires il ya plein d'autres choses à
faire tout de suite il faut pas qu'on se
trompe c'est plutôt de se parler entre
eux des signes de vie politique soyez
connaître aussi lui est complètement
complètement mais avant c'est pas trop
aller où je me suis exprimé toutes
celles et ceux qui de près ou loin en
jouant un rôle politique avec moi
administratifs doivent se tenir à
l'écart de l'ump pour l'intérêt de l'ump
soyez clair où vivent et qui tous ceux
qui ont été dans la campagne c'est pas
c'est pas clair ça c'est clair et
chagall c'est bien paix à nicolas
sarkozy mais tous même ceux qui ont eu
un rôle dont les noms ont été évoqués
mon sens ce n'est pas compliqué à
comprendre
faites pas semblant de ne pas comprendre
chaque inscrit chacun comprit voilà
parce qu'on n'arrivera pas à rebâtir
parce que derrière j'ai pas envie qu'il
ya encore un tourbillon judiciaire qui
viennent nous empêcher de jouer quoi
notre rôle d'opposant si marine le pen
est arrivé en tête lors des élections
européennes on ne m'enlèvera pas de
l'esprit c'est parce que pour les
français c'était lequel premier opposant
françois hollande or le premier opposant
président de la république c'est le
parti qui a vocation à être
l'alternative à créer l'alternance c'est
l'ump est aujourd'hui nous ne
remplissons plus ce rôle et moi j'ai pas
envie d'être spectateur et j'ai pas
envie que par nos erreurs par nos fautes
par notre comportement c'est nous qui
allie mention le réservoir à voix du
front national c'est pas notre vocation
notre vocation c'est d'être des
opposants
argumenté c'est d'être des proposant le
moment venu ce que ne fait pas le front
national et qu'à un moment donné les
français se dit c'est l'ump qui
incarnera l'avenir avec l'aide de décent
avec l'aide des centristes comme
partenaire évidemment comme partenaire
le mps que ce qu'était le mt à l'origine
avec les centres j'étais secrétaire
général de l'ump autour de la même table
dans l'union de la majorité elle va et
christine boutin il avait même philippe
de villiers et frédéric nihous il y
avait l'armée morin il y avait jean
louis borloo c'est ce que j'ai fait
quand j'étais secrétaire général c'est
donc possible
l'ump n'est plus audible aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui oui parce qu'elle est touché
très fortement par sa défaite à sa
défaite par le fait que sap arrivé en
tête aux élections européennes et cette
affaire bygmalion qui crée un vrai
climat de défiance auprès des
sympathisants ump j'ai cité ce sondage
un dd on retour de nicolas sarkozy a
clairement si les français établissent
ou non le sentiment que nicolas sarkozy
est responsable de cette faillite
financière ça sera extrêmement compliqué
pour lui dans un contexte où une
majorité de français ne souhaite pas son
retour mais ce qui est vrai c'est que
aujourd'hui l'ump est un parti qui a
gagné les élections municipales mais qui
n'apparaît pas comme une alternative au
pouvoir de françois hollande
le slogan que répètent à satiété les
leaders du front national l'ump est ce
ça devient pour beaucoup de français une
représentation au sens sociologique ils
nous disent dans nos enquêtes
qualitatives l'ump a échoué pendant cinq
ans les socialistes font moins bien
voire pires que nous reste-t-il beaucoup
de français donc se tourner vers le
front national qu'est-ce qui m'a passé
qu'est ce qui va se passer mardi au
bureau politique
il faut de l'apaisement il faut donc que
l'on valide clairement c'est cet
ensemble ce trio comme on l'appelle
françois fillon alain juppé jean pierre
raffarin pour donner de la stabilité et
il faudra aussi derrière qui est allé un
peu d'esprit des types la volonté de
tous bien david beeri mais de tout le
monde sans exception sans exception moi
même j'avais proposé au précédent bureau
politique qu'on vote dès le précédent
peut-être est-ce parce que j'ai je
dirigeais l'ump je sais que quand les
choses sont bien claires contient votre
bien clair ça facilite les choses pour
la suite le vote n'a pas eu lieu l'autre
mardi il va voir du mardi prochain et
dans ces conditions là ce trio avec
d'autres aura vocation à préparer le
congrès et puis aussi à faire vivre
l'ump au quotidien mais aussi à prendre
les dispositions qui s'imposent tout de
suite là plusieurs étapes mardi en est
une il y à la phase qui nous séparera du
congrès le congrès et puis surtout que
l'on parle aux français repose on parle
aux français et pourquoi je repousserai
certains disent que pour faciliter ce
mois les intéressent et puis lé statut
et vous savez pourquoi les statuts un
statut c'est pas les tables de la loi
les statuts ont été approuvés par qui
pas par un petit cénacle par les
adhérents celui qui est le vrai étable
pouvoir le plus important le plus
important celles adhérant vous savez
quoi on peut même l'avancé dans les
statuts le congrès vous seriez prêt à
avancer le congrès écoutez c'est une
décision qui sera collective mais les
statuts précisent bien que le congrès
qui est fixé là il était fixé ces dates
pour quoi pour ne pas gêner en quelque
sorte les élections qu'il y aura les
élections sénatoriales mais le plus tôt
ce sera clair mieux ce sera et le plus
fort ce sera clair la décision prise au
congrès mieux ce sera donc plutôt ce
sera nicolas sarkozy aussi aurait tout
intérêt à s'expliquer planète et mardi
de la semaine prochaine plutôt ce qu'il
veut faire alors je ne suis plus tôt
sera le mieux je ne suis plus son
porte-parole depuis la présidentielle de
2005 échappé il faut que je clarifie lui
aussi sa position il est là il est pas
là pour me choki clarifie sa chose ici
plus son porte-parole de pia xv de vie
pour cet éclairage merci alors on va
ouvrir une page international avec le
dossier bnp paribas la première banque
française est menacée par une amende qui
pourrait atteindre jusqu'à 16 milliards
de dollars ça fait un peu plus de 12 13
milliards d'euros tout cela parce
qu'elle est accusé par la justice
américaine d'avoir traité avec des pays
alors sous embargo françois hollande en
a parlé à paris avec barack obama mais
le président américain refusé de se
mêler de cette affaire écouter le
ministre des finances devant la
représentation nationale sur cette
affaire cette affaire est sérieuse
surtout parce que elle met en cause où
elle pourrait mettre en cause elle
risquerait de mettre en cause une grande
banque la première banque française la
deuxième banque européenne et donc à
partir de là les capacités pour cette
banque de participer à ce l'on nous
avons tellement besoin le financement de
notre économie
je ne voudrais pas que des décisions si
elles étaient inéquitables prij aux
états unis puissent mettre en cause la
capacité pour cette grande banque d'
apporter les financements nécessaires
aux pme pmi et eti et autres grandes
activités qui sont nécessaires à la
reprise de la croissance en france alors
question très simple quels moyens la
france at elle de se défendre dans cette
affaire face à la toute puissance
apparente de la justice américaine du
droit américain un de peser de se faire
respecter de porter ce dossier au niveau
européen et au niveau européen de deux
façons moi je souhaite que le président
de la banque centrale européenne se
saisisse cette question ça ne concerne
pas que la bnp et que le système
bancaire française se peut avoir des
répercussions sur le système bancaire
européen c'est donc aussi la
responsabilité de la banque centrale
européenne et quand je dis au niveau
européen vous savez que j'ai été depuis
maintenant un an en pointe pour dire que
le traité de libre échange
transatlantique recelait bien des
dangers mais là nous avons une arme s'il
faut s'en servir faisons le en demandant
la suspension des négociations en cours
la france n'est pas n'importe quel pays
la france est un pays qui compte qui
doit compter et qui peut demander cette
suspension plus bas dans le même sens
que vous mais un mois trop tard ça fait
un mois que l'on sait tout cela comment
se fait-il que ce soit depuis quelques
jours manque le gouvernement se mobilise
écoutez même s'ils se mobilisent tard
ils se mobilisent je suis prêt à
m'associer à cette mobilisation c'est
pas une question de droite ou de gauche
je veux dire deux choses supplémentaires
la première c'est que si la bnp a commis
des erreurs ou des fautes elle doit en
répondre mais là ce que cherche à faire
les américains c'est un assassinat de la
bnp n'avait qu'une telle amende mais
surtout avec l'interdiction d'exercer
pour tout ce qui concerne le commerce
avec les dollars c'est donc clairement
de dire la bnp terminée aux états unis
et la deuxième chose c'est que je ne
suis pas amoureux des banques loin s'en
faut parce qu'en france pour être
amoureux des banques qui ferait vraiment
qu'elle prête et qu'elle ne retire pas
bien souvent le financement ou la
trésorerie de toutes les petites
entreprises qui en ont besoin pour ceux
qui sont riches avoir de l'argent ce
n'est pas un problème pour ceux qui en
ont réellement besoin c'est un problème
en france ça n'enlève rien au fait qu'on
a beaucoup de comptes à demander aux
banques mais quand on veut aujourd'hui
s'en prendre à la bnp comme c'est le cas
on doit se mobiliser et je pose une
dernière question parce que tout est une
question de rapport de forces est ce que
vous pensez vraiment que les américains
auraient pris une telle décision
vis-à-vis d'une banque chinoise
je ne le crois pas qu'on ait france doit
être respectée déroulé jeudi parce que
des grands de ce monde débarque au
france
et ça va dans votre sens tout savoir
quelle est la voie et le poids de la
france aujourd'hui alors que barack
obama vladimir poutine sont arrivés à
paris dîner des chefs des tables avec
des tables séparées et arme ou d'un gars
va
recevoir pas moins de trois chefs d'état
voilà le programme chargé de françois
hollande aujourd'hui c'est la reine
elizabeth qui a ouvert le bal sa majesté
est arrivé en train à la gare du nord
elle a ensuite rejoint françois hollande
au pied de l'arc de triomphe au son de
god save the queen l'hymne du royaume
uni
puis à l'heure du thé entouré de la
garde républicaine
direction l'elysée la reine d'angleterre
et le président de la république se sont
entretenus pendant 40 minutes avant de
se retrouver demain la souveraine
britannique est l'invité d'honneur des
commémorations du débarquement
ensuite françois hollande enchaîne avec
deux dîners ou en langage diplomatique
un dîner et un souper car ces deux
autres ne voulaient pas se retrouver à
la même table le premier c'est barack
obama avec qui françois hollande dean en
ce moment même dans un restaurant étoilé
de la capitale au menu des discussions
des sujets qui fâchent dossier bnp et
inquiétudes américaines sur la livraison
de navires français à la russie plus à
21h souper avec vladimir poutine et
c'est l'ukraine qui occupera les deux
chefs d'état tout à l'heure à la fin du
g7 le président français c'est promu
entremetteurs entre le président russe
et son homologue ukrainien est ce que le
président poutine pourra rencontrer le
président roger cau oui puisque j'ai
invité le président pour autant qu tu
l'a vidé dès qu'il a été proclamé élu je
l'invitais précisément pour qu'il soit
là lui aussi et il sera là à côté du
président poutine le président poutine
on a été prévenus il vient il vient il
sait qu'il sera à côté en tout cas pas
loin du président ukrainien la semaine
diplomatique de françois hollande se
poursuit dès demain avec les
commémorations du débarquement
françois hollande la voix de la france
la france dans le monde comment est-ce
que vous jugez l'action du président en
matière de diplomatie on a pu le voir
avec les discussions avec barack obama à
vladimir poutine il y a deux choses sur
l'action extérieure ce que je soutiens
c'est la lutte contre le terrorisme et
le tram en notre action en afrique est
d'accord là dessus oui on entend parfois
des voix discordantes ce n'est pas le
cas en ce qui me concerne je pense que
la lutte contre le terrorisme doit être
portée en afrique dans certains pays
justement où il ya le berceau du
terrorisme je suis d'accord pour le
reste j'aimerais que la france soit
davantage respecté quelles soient
davantage entendus sur toute la crise
ukrainienne j'aurais aimé que le priant
de la république prenne des initiés il
aurait aimé que le prêt de la république
même se déplacer et vous voyez je suis
un opposant résolu je le fais
régulièrement entendre je fais
régulièrement tant de cette opposition
mais quand même jamais je ne reprocherai
auprès de la république de prendre des
initiatives même si elles ne sont pas
couronnées de succès le pire pour un
pays comme la france qui n'est pas un
prix moyen est une grande puissance qui
un siège au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
c'est de ne jamais être spectatrice mais
d'être actrice de premier plan on ne
sent pas le leadership bien sûr qu'on a
perdu de l'influencé las et ça je le
déplore tous les jours parce que on le
voit bien les menaces qui ont plané un
moment donné sur le budget de la défense
le simple fait de pouvoir envisager que
ces budgets fassent l'objet de coupe de
coupes budgétaires supplémentaires
c'était une faute voilà pourquoi il
était important d'éviter le pire mais
qu'il faut rester vigilant sur tous ces
sujets oui j'aimerais un présent qui
aille de l'avant et qu'ils fassent
respecter la france petite question de
défense justement est-ce que la la la
france a intérêt à se fâcher avec la
russie de vladimir poutine ce qu'elle
doit vendre ces bpc bâtiment de
projection et de commandement à la
russie sont déjà vendus ils sont vendus
jura n'est pas pourquoi revenir parce
que les américains nous le demandent et
puis quoi encore est ce que nous on
donne des conseils aux américains sur
leur choix finances 6 1 sur l'année
d'autre part est ce que ce sont ces ces
bateaux là qui vont avoir une incidence
sur ce qui est en train de se passer
c'est bien c'est bien que non voilà mais
pour le reste je n'aime pas qu'on nous
dicter notre conduite c'est une question
d'indépendance et de souveraineté
nationale les américains sont nos alliés
c'est vrai m alors qu'ils se comportent
comme des alliés al respectueux
justement on ouvre une page histoire
comment l'opération du dj et a pu être
monté c'est la question que pose le
réalisateur pascal vuong auteur d'un
documentaire époustouflant sur ce jour j
qui nous replonge dans le contexte de
l'époque avec des images de synthèse ce
film sera diffusé dans le monde entier
regarder ces extraits avec simon
barbarie
il s'appelle john winston violette
edward white
ils viennent des quatre coins du monde
et cet été là ils se retrouvent tous
pour libérer l'homme le débarquement
comme vous y étiez enfin presque c'est
le projet du réalisateur pascal burg son
documentaire dit dès 1944 retrace les
enjeux géostratégiques et toute
l'ingéniosité des préparatifs de cette
gigantesque opération militaire qui a vu
le jour il ya maintenant 70 ans
carte infographique reconstitution avec
acteurs ou encore insertion de films
d'animation ce film de 40 minutes en
trois dimensions se veut exhaustif
pascal burg apporte une touche française
à cette reconstitution historique toutes
les nations qui ont participé au jour j
sont ici évoquée sans oublier de
rappeler les vingt mille civils normand
mort durant l'été 44
spectaculaire et pédagogique le dj
normandie 44 et le premier film français
sur le sujet destinées aux écrans géants
un documentaire à voir ce week-end à la
géode à paris au zénith de caen et dans
de nombreuses luttes d'une
soixante dix ans après xavier bertrand
l'europe et la france doivent tel dire
merci aux américains oui bien sûr jamais
ricains et puis à tous leurs alliés à
tous nos alliés moi je suis très
respectueux du sacrifice parce que il ya
bien sûr la liberté qu'on a retrouvé
liberté qui est préservée mais et tous
ces hommes qui sont qui sont venus loin
de chez eux et qu'ils ont trouvé la mort
peut se souvenir d'eux en priorité et
puis la deuxième chose c'est de
considérer que la paix la liberté ne
sont jamais des acquis définitif ou tour
se battre toujours se battre pour eux et
puis après
de son histoire ça doit certainement
être humain parfois de regarder son
intérêt à court terme et d'avoir des
visions belliqueuse il faut sauvegarder
fois c'est aussi pourquoi il faut des
organisations qu'ils soient régulatrice
qu'ils puissent aussi garantir la paix
pour peser pour que la paix s'impose et
puis le dernier point je voyais ces
images de synthèse et la prouesse
technologique du film et les images de
synthèse c'est rien c'est rien par
rapport à la prouesse à l'époque
l'ingéniosité et d'avoir réussi à faire
croire que ça ne serait pas à cet
endroit là le débarquement que tout ait
pu rester secret pour donner la force
d'action la force d'intervention et la
place à la victoire c'est remarquable ça
laisse vraiment
rêveur et leur dire chapeau japon
chapeau pour le sacrifice et et chapeau
pour pour cet exercice semblable ce sera
le mot de la fin la france remercie
d'avoir répondu à l'invitation de parler
me rizzo surtout la semaine prochaine à
5 4 la semaine prochaine c'est à tous de
votre fidélité à très bientôt